もう開けちゃったんですけど
macbook air
すぎ
ん
まあやっと買えましたね届いた時の動画があるんですけど
天孫がひどすぎるんでダイジェストだけつけました
どうぞ
おっ
うわーうわーうわー
なにこれ
腹をわっ
青いなさいよっ
仕上げ行っ東変えたんですよ macbook が大
幣ねこうホラー
薄すぎですよねぇ
先月はバイトばっかりしてもう macbook 買ってもねもう全然
もう板でも書いても
あるんですけど黒とエアー
という2種類があるんですけどなんでやんでしたって言ったら
まず薄いんです
ホンダリスだったろう方
薄い
さらに
macbook pro と比べて薄いんですけどゾーブらしいですね
macbook pro わーノートパソコンなくて性能が良すぎるらしくて
なんかもうすごい壊れやすいやすいですノートパソコンに
メッツ凝縮しすぎて
一箇所壊れたら全部効率はみたいな
小ねぎして作ってあるそうですよ噂ですけど
っていうのも考えたらアクティブプレイヤーにしました
朝からて生間に帰るんですよ実家ではズレがあっ
学校サボって実家でも動画だすたいんでー
って no
これを the file パソコン持ってなくていま
なんだよ
買っちゃいました macbook これずっと windows 使ってたから
すごいはやりにくいね様のマックがう
どんなに戦線はわかんないなかっ
分からない部分へどうぞ
うん
パックで一まくりっ
ファイル
scape
うんっ
ネスペも by プロシンプルでは大きい10倍にするんじゃねえ
長靴の国の強くですん
os 10ギガぽいそうだと呼ばれる仕組みとなることをうまく使いこなせるように
なりたいです
好きだよ実家に帰ります
ことにもバイト頑張った甲斐がありましたよ
かっこよくいいですよこれ
じゃああー